North Las Vegas Police say man is dead
tonight after being shot by officers
thank you for joining us at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez it happened
just outside the MLK senior center near
MLK and Kerry that's where we find Ryan
Matthey joining us now live with uh what
happened there tonight Ryan
yeah Denise and Brian more than 50
people have stood on this side of Kerry
Avenue for hours all the while on the
other side of Cary Avenue police have
been investigating this officer-involved
shooting North Las Vegas Police saying
one of their officers shot and killed a
man allegedly yielding a gun the man who
has not been identified yet was
allegedly pointing his gun towards
multiple people in the area that
includes at a nearby mini-mart police
responded and found the man wearing a
Michael myers-styled Halloween mask in
the Park police say they repeatedly
asked this man to stop walking and when
he refused police say he attempted to
escape by foot that's when the guns were
drawn they say and one of those 50
people here tonight is the woman
claiming to be the deceased mother she
alleges that she was prevented from
seeing or identifying her son for hours
tonight and shares in the grief of these
onlookers wondering why less violent
means were not taken to suppress the
suspect
if the guy across the street at the post
at the car wash he told me what's going
on but I need them to tell me what's
going on why you shoot my son why you
shoot him in his back because he took
off running you could have shot him with
a a pellet a taser anything if he he did
nothing it took off running that's no
reason to shoot nobody
now police say this was the only person
killed in this shooting the mother
claims officers shot 17 times in her
son's back police would not confirm how
many shots were fired and as for the
shooting officer North Las Vegas Police
say that person is on paid
administrative leave uninjured from the
shooting and as for why less violent
means were not taken to suppress the
suspect and what is that body camera
footage show we are expecting to get all
of that in the coming days that's per
North Las Vegas Police for now reporting
near Kerry and MLK Ryan Matthey 8 News
Now